all right well even though it's only
monday we are getting ready to cheers to
next weekend it's the tropicana wine
mixer that's the name of the event it's
happening this weekend it's a three-day
wine festival and here to tell us all
about it is the head of food and
beverage for tropicana las vegas richard
swaboda richard thank you so much for
being here thank you for having me so
let's talk wine is my favorite
four-letter word i just have to say so
i'm really excited about this it's the
first time you're doing this festival
tell us all about it and what people can
expect so well it's a three-day event
starts on friday we will have a check-in
and registration on friday with some
wine and appetizers and
some hors d'oeuvres and then saturday we
go right into full swing
we'll have all of our education classes
so there'll be a combination of
different things to choose from and it
can be
wine pairing with cheese it can be wine
education we're having a mixing class
so there's four different events
we're also going to have lunch
and a happy hour and then the following
day we will have uh the hangover brunch
so if you're going to be having a lot of
wine you need a lot of food to go along
with it and
these are open bottles in front of me we
have to take a taste of a few so i'll
have you run me through you said we're
going to taste a little bit of each one
something your favorite what are we
starting with okay so we're going to
start with the stagsleep
sauvignon blanc this is a napa valley
sauvignon blanc
light crispy
goes great with fish chicken
salads cheers to monday right cheers to
monday
tell us a little bit i know we have a
lot of different events you mentioned
the brunch and the happy hour what can
people take part in when it comes to
learning about wine and just getting
more educated with it sure sure so the
pairing is one of the great classes that
we're going to do
learned a pair of cheese and wine
together which is a fun thing to do at
home
and we also will do a wine blending
seminar with kendall jackson so they're
they're going to blend different types
of wines and taste different profiles so
that'll be fun as well
i also forgot to mention as well too we
have dinner that night as well which is
an additional cost to the um the
cost for the package
but it's a three-course meal it's going
to be fantastic and that is paired with
wine as well wow that sounds amazing and
this wine was amazing so let's move on
to the next one so we're going to taste
i'm loving this assignment today you
guys from jc making sushi we're drinking
wine it's a party in here on monday
we're doing it right okay what's this
one so this is the rodney strong chalk
hill chardonnay so this is going to be a
little bit of butter and oak
another great white wine to go with fish
chicken as well especially with cream
sauces or butter sauces well this is
delicious and these are my kind of wine
glasses these are huge and if people
still want to attend are tickets still
available where can they get them yeah
so tickets are on sale they can go to
tropilv.com to our website and has all
the information
we will sell them at the event on friday
if someone would like to come down and
purchase tickets there and then we also
have our box office at tropicana as well
well this sounds like a party it sounds
like a lot of fun and we do still have
some wine left but we have to wrap so i
think you might have to give me a little
education on this as the day goes on
thank you so much there's all the
information on your screen this weekend
it's a tropicana wine mixer it's going
to be a lot of fun
i